wtf hallöchen freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge lost ich
bin wieder in dieser tollen f5 ansicht
nach als auch relativ egal ich möchte
mich erst mal kurz oder hinten ist ein
schaf erst mal kurz bei euch allen
entschuldigen dafür dass letztes
wochenende keine lust kam und davor das
wochenende auch nicht davor das
wochenende war ganz einfach die
klausurphase hat begonnen und ich habe
es ehrlich gesagt dann auch ein bisschen
vernachlässigt mit youtube hat schon
vorher viel aufgenommen damit ich mich
aufs lernen konzentrieren konnte habe
ich aber eigentlich ganz gut gemeistert
und letztes wochenende war es einfach so
dass ich in paris war und da hatte ich
schon viel zu tun mit dem vorher
hochladen bild vom theater show von
desert race land so weiter von daher
hatte ich da auch nicht so die hammer
mäßige zeit das alles noch lost
hochzuladen bei seine folge lost 40
minuten dauert schon dann hochladen in
meinem internet you're a 67 stunden oder
so also ich hab da nicht beste leitung
die sonne geht übrigens geht unter aber
ich war jetzt in paris wir alle die wir
bei facebook gefolgt haben facebook link
in der beschreibung wenn der vom
neuesten stand sein wollt die wissen
dass ich in paris war was hab ich in
paris gemacht ganz einfach ich habe
urlaub gemacht und zwar mit meiner
familie mal wieder ganz ganz schön alt
und so weiter familie wegfahren
eigentlich ganz cool
und da kann ich euch auch ein wenig
darüber erzählen da habe ich gedacht
dass das ein warmer heute mache und zwar
fällt mir auf dass ich gar keine fackeln
dabei habe damit übrigens bin ich
vollständig wieder gesund ich hab zwar
ab und an noch so einen komischen husten
oder so einen komischen husten geschmack
ich weiß nicht genau wie ich das sagen
soll aber ein neuer ist halt nicht so
nicht so toll dass sich halt noch dieses
komische diesen husten halt so ein
bisschen aber allgemein geht es mir so
erstmal wesentlich besser als vorher
irgendwann mal
naja jedenfalls wollte ich heute in
dieser aufnahme session ein wenig bei
paris quatschen und ihr müsst jetzt auch
gar nicht sagen
aber dort ist auch so gut geplant mit
lost und alles und jetzt haben wir zwei
folgen nicht kriegt ja ich weiß jetzt
zwei folgen nicht bekommt allerdings
habe ich gedacht dass irgendwann dann in
der woche lässt kommt oder dass ich
heute einfach mal eine sehr lange
station mache oder irgendwann noch mal
und dann gleicht sich das eigentlich aus
ich gucke mir jetzt erstmal ein paar top
shops weil das ist ja das geil auch in
minecraft mein leben verliert musste in
der neuesten version also in der summe 1
punkt 3.2 also in der ganzen wir sind
gerade in der beta 1.5 aber in der neuen
die gerade raus ist natürlich die
1.3.2011 verliert beziehungsweise
schaden bekommt dass man erst mal was
essen muss dann fühlt sich erstmal diese
hunger leiste ich auf und dann generiert
sich so alle fünf sekunden ein halbes
herzchen
das finde ich echt schon ganz einfach
und zwar einfach in der höhe weshalb
jetzt einmal ganz schnell die
hintereinander jetzt necken man muss ja
nicht mal irgendwie gedrückt halten oder
somit ist die einfach so direkt und dann
hat man direkt wieder volles leben als
ist ganz cool und ich habe mir heute
auch schon also thema paris folgt
darüber quatschen was also war ich war
ja ein paar tage dort ich war sonntag
losgefahren und donnerstag wieder zurück
und da wo ich ein bisschen drüber
quatschen und vor allem praktisch jetzt
bestimmen taylor quatschen und bauen
gleichzeitig kannst du doch nicht so gut
das stimmt das kann ich wirklich nicht
so gut nein nein
scheiße jetzt kommt bestimmt irgendwie
skelette oder so ich bin doch nicht gut
ich weiß das kann ich nicht so gut
deswegen habe ich mir eine beschäftigung
ausgesucht für diese folge deswegen wird
die wahrscheinlich auch ein wenig länger
gehen und zwar werde ich eine monster
falle bauen
ich glaube wir haben ja letztes mal ein
monsters bonner gefunden
finde ich auf jeden fall sehr gut dass
wir ihn gefunden haben weil ich mir
schon gedanken bei eine falle und so
weiter gemacht habe
und naja also wenn es erst mal wissen
was zu essen die schaufel ich brauche
vier augen wtf
ach du scheiße das ist echt so kacke
hier creeper zu besiegen ok cool pfeiler
habe ich aber das ist ganz gut
ich versuche es jetzt einfach mal mit
pfeilen sehr geld natürlich jetzt
einfach immer mit pfeilen das ganz gut
geht dass auf jeden fall besser weil bei
der neuesten version ist ja so broich
vergleich dass man mit der neuesten
version am egal da kannst du dir einfach
so sprinten und dann schlagen dann
fielen die richtig weit weg und so und
das gilt der mittlerweile nicht mehr
beruf gut okay hier ging es runter zum
monster falle aber was uns der krieg
gerade frei gesprengt hat das wundert
mich ein bisschen
also ich weiß nicht was dienstfrei
gesprengt hat moment ich hol mir mal
ganz kurz ein bisschen sand oder ich
lage allgemein mal kurz ein paar sachen
so cool dass lassen der uns hier ist das
eine höhle das ist irgendwann so ein
gebilde hier über dich ich möchte ganz
kurz oder nee ist keine hülle gut müssen
uns keine sorgen darum machen ich fand
es jetzt nur ein wenig beängstigend dass
hier auf einmal so ein okay ist wirklich
nichts dass hier auf einmal so viele
frei gesprengt wurde ich meinen dass
dort keine nie vor sein moment deswegen
ehrmann
ich wollte schon wieder shift drücken
dann ging das nicht dass wir jetzt
einfach mal mit fenster und so ein
bisschen verankern
das wollte ich nicht moment da kommt ein
händler da so ihr merkt schon während
des bauens hier kann ich wirklich nicht
so gut quatschen
aber das wird sich gleich besser denn
gleich werden einfach mal die monster
falle ausheben bzw werde ich euch dann
ganz kurz sagen wie ich mir das
vorstelle
zwar brauche ich erstmal noch
nein ich hab schon wieder die play taste
gedrückt weil ich ja noch nicht dazu so
und so
also paris ich bin oder nicht ich mir
erstmal ganz kurz wie ich mir das mit
dem monster fälle vorgestellt habe und
zwar da wo ich mir ganz kurz die sachen
die ich benötige und zwar bräuchte
phänomen zacken
deswegen habe ich mir das ganze reisen
was besser du gehst erstmal darunter
damit ich dich nicht im anklicke
deswegen habe ich mal das ganze essen
hier gemacht da und zwar davon mag ich
auch ein paar ach das geht wiederum naja
hey cool ich habe noch einen vollständig
den vollen ich blöd man den müller man
müsste uns auch mal machen so mit cola
und so kommission nämlich mit moment
wollte ich euch stehen nochmal sticks
verdächtiges überhaupt holz das holz was
ich hier wieder für bullshit alles im
inventar
also ich wollte mir eine neue schaufel
machen falls die alte eventuell
irgendwann kaputt geht dann will ich
mein neues schwert machen und eine neue
pc's und wenn wir gerade dabei sind kann
ich mir theoretisch auch noch eine neun
kleine haus sondern eine axt machen
ok ich lade euch einfach mal hier wir
haben denke ich genug sachen zum
abmahnung da ich brauche eventuell noch
einen eimer beziehungsweise 2
beziehungsweise ich mache mir erst mal
war ich gehe immer zum falschen so
naumann alles geht schief
also wir bauen uns jetzt erstmal eine
unendliche wasserquelle als wird schon
wieder fastnacht so
jetzt geht's los mit der monster falle
ich zeige euch mal ganz kurz wie ich das
mein und wenn wir dann um ausheben sind
dann geht's weiter
es seien auch welche gesagt du hast du
die map vorher angeguckt du weißt ja wo
genau alle sachen sind nein es ich mein
ich finde man nimmt sich total den spaß
und das ist auch einer der gründe warum
ich les player geworden bin dass ich
einfach nicht mehr geht und warum sollte
ich mit einem web vorher angucken allem
apps die ich bisher let's play cup und
die attac waren so einige
ich habe ich mir nicht vorher angeguckt
science adventure web sei es ganz
normales let's play sei es irgendeinen
together zum beispiel bei der türkei der
schau die mehr platz auch nicht vorher
angeguckt und eigentlich finde ich die
map hier ziemlich geil und ich hatte
eigentlich richtig glück mit der
erstellung und na ja also ich kann nur
sagen dass ich mir die maps eigentlich
nicht angucke weil ich diesen
überraschungsfaktor ganz gut finde
so also was ich gedacht habe kann ich
irgendwie helligkeit hochstellen oh mein
gott ich spiele auf hart ich bin mal auf
diese deswegen wundert auch tagsüber die
ganzen leute da ach so dass er ganz
sicher erst mal kurz ab weil da will ich
nichts mit zu tun haben so ich wollte
dass hier so quasi warum habe ich das
eigentlich wollte das in der mitte
dieser dieser scorer ist von den
skeletten und dass ich quasi diese
fläche hier lasse wo dies bauen können
und dann mache ich hier so wasser flüsse
nach dahin dahin dahin und dahin und
anschließend wieder quasi runterfallen
in so ein sammelbecken und dann ja dann
fallen die halt darunter dann mache ich
das so eine lava fall also dass die dann
so ein lover reingehen und ja ich hatte
erst gedachten xp form zu machen
allerdings bringt das nicht sonderlich
viel dafür in dieser version xp anfangen
können wir sehen dass xp noch gar nicht
gibt
ein bisschen aussieht sieht damit ihr
das seht also ich kann immer direkt
anfangen paris wir sind am sonntag
losgefahren sonntag war der moment ich
guck mal ganz kurz damit ungefähr ist
von bodyguard rede warnte wille von tag
von tag genau am tag der neue tag
allemal sonntag in die konter erscheint
der sonntag war der siebzehnte wir sind
losgefahren morgens um also morgens um
acht uhr bin ich aufgestanden
losgefahren sind wir erst um 11 das
wohnzimmer sowie sagen ja wir fahren
hier schon um 9 los steht auf 8 auf und
ich sein befand er es 50.000 stunden
später das war dann auch der fall dass
wir echt noch ein bisschen länger
gebraucht haben bis wir dann endlich mal
losgefahren sind aber egal das täglich
dazu egal sowie online auf [ __ ] [ __ ]
anschlüssen ist sofort etwas einfaches
bond einfach sofort was hier
menschliches auch kaputt da muss ich
gleich richtig aufpassen wegen diesen
blöden mehr hier
naja war das erst mal ein bisschen zu es
war halt der siebte und wir sind dann
losgefahren irgendwann so gegen 11 10 11
uhr so ungefähr um den dreh keine ahnung
jedenfalls den wieder losgefahren
produkt über die straße es war immens
viel staub richtig glück hatten wir mit
dem steuer sitzt einfach alles voll auf
den straßen
wir haben dann irgendwie sieben stunden
gebraucht im auto bis sie dann in paris
waren sehr nahe gekommen
ja wir sind nicht geflogen sondern mit
dem auto gefahren und dann waren wir
dann halt in paris erst mal sachen ins
hotel dann zum eiffelturm rüber gewahrt
stellt und der ist echt krass groß die
spitze war im nebel bis in den wolken
es lag wahrscheinlich daran dass es an
dem tag relativ neblig war aber man hat
schon gesehen dass dieses teil echt
events großes und das da wundere ich
mich echt immer wieder zum beispiel auch
beim kölner dom dass menschen die so
lange vor uns gelebt haben und dieses
ding erbaut haben also beim eiffelturm
ist es jetzt nicht so lange wie beim
kölner dom aber trotzdem zb beim kölner
dom dass die trotzdem diese komplette
architektur so einen sinn dafür hatten
da war wirklich alles symmetrisch zum
beispiel beim eiffelturm unter an
im kölner dom ist ja auch so das recht
alle jede wende überall sind torbögen im
gleichen abstand angeordnet so weit dass
meine und das finde ich einfach nur
bewundernswert dass die da wirklich das
so hingekriegt haben damals schon finde
ich echt sehr interessant und naja da
man weiter beim eiffelturm sind dann
irgendwo etwas essen wird das essen
gegangen und ich werde das immer ganz
kurz mit cobblestone aus sind dann halt
was essen gegangen
direkt daneben war eigentlich so ein
restaurant wo es direkt daneben locker
schon kilometer weg das waren dann eher
von sushi dingens und na ja keine ahnung
ist egal jedenfalls wasser hat ganz
coolen dann haben wir uns gesagt ja
kommen morgen und die nächsten tage soll
es eigentlich regnen deswegen werden wir
nun mal versuchen auf den eiffelturm zu
gehen und das hat dann echt geklappt
dass wir dann da drauf gehen konnten auf
diesen elf turm es tag oder nacht ist
noch tag noch estag dass wir da drauf
gehen konnten das hat nicht geklappt das
eigentlich ganz cool und zwar weder
wirklich da hoch gegangen
beziehungsweise nicht gegangen sondern
muss hinten angestellt und da war dann
erstmal so halbe stunde anstehen und so
vereitelt umgeht dass also die leute
haben uns gesagt als wieder gesagt haben
eiffelturm ist schon echt wenig da waren
hinter uns auch deutsche das ist echt
immens krass wie viele deutsche und wie
viele rolle als in paris gibt wie viele
deutsche das ist immens kassel richtig
richtig viele deutsche gesehen könnte
denken es ist eine deutsche stadt mit
ein bisschen paris französische im
hintergrund oder so keine ahnung
naja jedenfalls auf den eiffelturm
gegangen und mit diesem komischen aufzug
hoch gefahren aber noch die zweite etage
die zweite tasche schon 200 meter hoch
und ganz hoch ist glaube ich 330 oder
irgendwie so und wir wollten nämlich
noch die höchste etage nordast leider
noch mal mehr gekostet und da hatten
jetzt nicht allzu viel bock drauf noch
mal geld zu bezahlen außerdem was im
nebel das heißt man hätte nur ein wenig
von dem boden unter einem gesehen und
naja war jetzt nicht so notwendig sage
ich mal 45 watt ich muss euch erzählen
sie macht ok haben wir dann gesagt nee
kommt lassen war dann gehen wir lieber
woanders rheinufer oder so und naja das
war dann so der erste tag dann sind wir
relativ spät nach
so gegen halb zwölf und das geile war
auch ich hatte mit meiner schwester ein
zimmer also die ist drei jahre jünger
als ich die ist 13
und meine eltern hatten zusammen ein
zimmer und werden seine zwischentüren
dann konnte ich ihr könnt mir halt
abends immer noch so keine ahnung
fernseher gucken videos gucken und so
weiter das eigentlich ganz cool 5678
wenn ich das jetzt richtig gerechnet
habe
fließt das wasser genau bis da und zum
beispiel da nicht rein
ich hoffe ich habe das richtig berechnet
ja okay es gut aber ich muss trotzdem
noch ein zwei drei mal holen und ich
glaube das ist nicht so gut weil es ist
gerade acht egal ich brauche mal die
arme weiter das muss ich ihn noch offen
lassen
ja das war dann der erste tag dann am
montag der zweite tag sinn war morgens
waren wir im hotel frühstück das erste
mal frühstücken und das war echt ich
fand es nicht so gut also das einzige
was die hatten war wirklich tust actimel
und nutella
vielmehr hatten ihren spaß und so alles
aber naja das war dann halte der zweite
teil dann aufgestanden dann los gegangen
und wollten dann halt über die wollten
zum triumphbogen also das ist ein großer
bogen der wurde damals zu ehren
napoleons glaube ich gebauten abholen
sollte euch allen wenigstens schon mal
zuhören gekommen sein sonst könnt ihr
euch direkt irgendwo ein graben oder so
julians blogs seien keine ahnung also
der sollte eigentlich schon euch allen
bekannt sein es war ein französischer
kaiser der sich selber zum kaiser
gekrönt hat und dann ziemlich viele
kriege geführt hat auch erfolgreich
unter anderem gegen deutschland ich weiß
ja aber england auch angegriffen hat
aber gegen deutschland auf jeden fall
und neue jedenfalls hat er daher zum
triumphbogen gebaute ist immens groß und
also wenn anhalt hochgegangen wirklich
stufen der 20 200 stufen und weiß wie
lange ich das jetzt gebaut 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 mache ich das doch einfach mal
zehn lang hat er dann halt gebaut
also hat er endlich gebaut sondern hat
der bauen lassen versteht sich und
jedenfalls sind wir dann halt da
reingegangen und hatten dann von oben
halten richtig haben wir ausblick
wenn ich es schaffe ich das schaffe ich
dachte dass ich eventuell sind geraten
bild einblenden könnte aber das geht
nicht weil meine kamera zurzeit ein
wenig kaputt ist und die sd-karte
wahrscheinlich alle fotos wechseln die
ich in paris gemacht habe vor allem muss
ich da gucken vielleicht poste ich
irgendwann noch mal ein foto auf
facebook wo dann so ja hier von wegen
lässt folge drei hier habe ich ja
angebot angedeutet und soweit dies dass
ihr eure foto oder irgendwie sowas keine
ahnung
eventuell mache ich das nämlich jetzt 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 und hier ist dann zehn
gut ja also das war dann so der zweite
tag wo wir dann rollt auf den
triumphbogen waren und so und jedenfalls
war es dann aber auch so dass wir nach
dem triumphbogen der es ist quasi der
mittelpunkt von paris alle straßen alle
großen straßen
ich höre etwas nicht bewegen erführen
wirklich zum triumphbogen was ganz
entrückt ich höre spinnen welche
angegriffen
also wirklich alle straßen in paris alle
etwas bedeutungs da hinten sind bei
monster alle straßen die ein ganz klein
bisschen bedeutung haben in paris führen
wirklich zum triumphbogen und ich werde
jetzt vielleicht kommt uns den höfen
hierbei noch nicht cool
alle straßen führen wirklich also alle
großen straßen mit so ganz viel bäume
und so weiter die führen wirklich alle
zum triumphbogen was ich sehr
interessant findet dass die damals
wirklich schon alles darauf ausgerichtet
haben dass da irgendwann so ein bogen
sein wird der dann wo dann alle straßen
hin fühlen werden uns das wirklich alle
straßen führen dorthin sowie alle wege
führen nach rom und so weiter also ich
denke ihr wisst ungefähr was ich sagen
möchte
na ja also das fand ich ganz interessant
und dann außerdem eine chance die
dorthin führt ist die chance diese
kausalität sollte euch allen bekannt
sein ist somit einer der größten
shopping straßen in
europa oder es ist sogar die größte
glaube ich ist einfach richtig krass wie
viele und welche leben wird alle
vertreten sind also wirklich rauf und
runter von totalen schnösel läden wie
louis vuitton alles bis über so hip hop
läden bis über bibliotheken des über sex
shops da ist alles vertreten
und das war halt ganz interessant dort
auch wie viele leben dort wirklich sind
ich wollte mir eigentlich schuhe kaufen
welche schuhe jacke ist man halt nix
also neuen ikt so rot-weiße waren das
design halt extrem geil lassen die
hatten sie halt nicht in meiner größe
deswegen weil halt schon relativ durch
das heißt im grunde genommen habe ich
mir dann gar nichts gekauft dort obwohl
es seit relativ groß war
naja jedenfalls war mir dann halt
ungefähr sechs stunden lang auf dieser
chance ließ wir sind einfach in jedem
laden was rein da gab es auch so
komische disney leiden da wollte meine
schwester unbedingt rein und so weiter
also das war schon ganz interessant dort
und dann nachher nach der champs elysées
sind wir dann noch nachher zudem zu dem
ich sag mal zudem reichenviertel oder
kann man das so nennen also zu einem
schönen viertel in frankreich gegangen
also in paris gegangen wo wir dann halt
auch was gegessen haben die restaurants
waren alle sehr günstig muss ich
wirklich sagen nur die haben halt alle
sehr viel trinkgeld verlangt
beziehungsweise allgemeinen nach
trinkgeld zu verlangen ist ein wenig
doof finde ich weil trinkgeld ist
freiwillig muss man nicht geben wenn er
das antippen kommt more money money
money und wir so ok und na ja keine
ahnung
jedenfalls haben wir dann halt ans essen
sind dann auch wieder zugegen elf nach
hause und ja das war dann halt so der
zweite tag der montag am dienstagmorgen
zu einem ball schiffs hof gefahren also
bahn bahnhof gleich mal momente wie weit
ist das letzte 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
es muss drei treffer drauf
da sind wir dann halt hingegangen
zusammen zum zum hafen da also nicht zum
hafen es gibt ja überall wirklich
anbindungen zu helfen und so weiter also
überall können da wirklich schiffe
meinen dass er ist überall stehen da
wirklich schiffe am rand von der saint
also dass er den fluss der dadurch
frankreich geht und da sind wir dann
halt ein bisschen rum gewatschelt und
haben da dann halt ein boot gesehen
welches wirklich immer so eine eine
strecke ab gras sage ich mal
also das feld immer von eiffel turm über
chance diese übergriffe war alles
mögliche zu her und macht dann halt
überall stopps und man kann halt überall
einsteigen und aussteigen und kanada
führungen mitmachen und so weiter das
haben wir dann gesagt ja kommt machen
wir mal endlich ein wenig so die touris
die sich dass ein stadtplan nehmen und
alles abgrasen sondern einfach nur ein
bisschen rumlaufen bis zum chillen in
der stadt und warten was das ganze so
mit sich bringt und was man so eventuell
sehen kann aber das war echt geil
also da hast du dir wirklich für fünf
euro schiffs ticket gekauft konnte ist
dann wirklich wir sind beim eiffelturm
eingestiegen wir unser hotel war auch im
einzel turm wissen wahrscheinlich alle
die die bei facebook sind und so sind
dann da eingestiegen sind weitergefahren
zum louvre ein bisschen besser erstmal
zum notre dame das ist diese e-mails
große kirche die haben wir dann
besichtigt dann weiter zum louvre und am
louvre der war geschlossen dienstags das
war total blöd das hatten wir vorher
nicht im internet nach geguckt und das
war halt nicht so toll
jedenfalls wartet dann so dass wir dann
da beim juve waren der wald geschlossen
und wir konnten dann halt nichts machen
dann sehen wir mal in den restaurant
gesetzt und sind dann wieder zu chancen
die see gegangen und wollte nochmal bei
einem offiziellen nike store gucken der
darauf war nach mainz nicht mehr kaufen
wollte und die frau war so was von
unhöflich verkäuferin müssen englisch
können dass die müssen einfach englisch
können das ist einfach so dass lernen
die wenn sie das studieren oder keine
ahnung dass die müssen einfach englisch
können und die konnte kein englisch ich
sagte josef this one's in red und zeigst
du auf die schuhe weil die hatten die
nun blau und ich habe schon blaue schuhe
deswegen ich wollte den rot-weiß organ
ich sage sollte uns in red
foto foto foto foto just that also ich
wollte einfach nur die farbe sehen wie
die aussehen wie es aussieht und sie
kriegt das echt nicht gebacken mich zu
verstehen habe ich gesagt also auf
englisch als weiße jetzt lasse ich geh
jetzt ich gucke woanders tschüss also
habe ich das so betont ich geld in einen
anderen laden kauft da die schuhe und
dann hast du pech gab so nach dem motto
aber na ja weil ich halt nicht ganz so
toll drauf jedenfalls war mein vater
auch mit der stadt neben ihren halt ein
bisschen gelacht weil ich halt schon
gegen die frau so ein bisschen
vorgegangen bin aber ich finde wenn man
so unhöflich ist verkäuferin dann sollte
man den verrückt nicht ausleben aber das
ist egal jeden fall irgendwann kam ich
gerade
naja egal irgendwie bin ich aus dem menü
geflogen wird gar nicht wollte ich höre
ja die kanzlei irgendwas läuft es egal
jedenfalls war ich dann sehr traurig und
dann wollte meine schwester noch bei den
rewe tor rein also die hat sich da
nichts gekauft sondern sie wollten auf
einem kumpel 700 euro für eine tasche
ist echt schon bescheuert
ganz im ernst ist es scheiße und ich
finde die sehen nicht nur gut aus naja
damit hat man halt wie bei apple einfach
1000 euro für die marke und 100 euro für
den moment werde tasche 500 kostet man
bezahlt 1000 euro für die marke dann
werde etwas faul dabei galt so dass
walter also der dritte tag dann sind wir
halt abends wieder nach hause gegen
elfen ich jetzt mal wieder ein paar
fackeln damit ihr passiert ach ich bin
ja soo sozialen ein spaß club stinkt
und ja dann sind wir pennen gegangen
irgendwann so gegen eins bin ich erst
konnte ich als einpendler echt extrem
behindert weil dann hatte ich morgens
auch rückenschmerzen und alles ändert
war echt hammer geil auf jeden fall
hammer geil auf jeden fall
dann kamen der vorletzte tag der
mittwoch deutschen wieder morgens
aufgestanden sind los gedeckelt und sind
mit dem taxi wieder zum louvre gefahren
und haben dort angesehen dass der offen
hat aber da war echt eine schlange also
der louvre ist ja so ein riesiges museum
da kann man locker mal zehn stunden lang
drin bleiben wenn man sich alles
angucken will da ist übrigens auch
mcdonald's und aber ist egal jedenfalls
waren wir dann halt dort drin
dort drin sondern dort drin und also
nicht dort drin sondern auf diesem platz
auf diesem vorplatz für diese gläserne
pyramide steht das ist ganz berühmt
diese pyramide weil das es halt der
eingang zu dem ding und dieses schlange
gehe nicht um die ganze pyramide rum und
dann nochmal zweites mal rum das heißt
man hätte locker locker sechs stunden
allein anstehen müssen das war schlimmer
als opfer gamescom und alle die auf der
gamescom an wissen was anstehen heisst
naja jedenfalls sind wir dann halt nicht
eingegangen weil jeder vernünftige
mensch für tagen kein pop sechs stunden
stehen die vier stunden oder drin also
na ja naja war mir dann halt nicht drin
und dann machen wir wieder in dem
restaurant in dem wir auch am 2 am
dienstag waren wo das zug hatte haben da
wieder was gegessen und sind dann weiter
zu
108 dabei im sonne auch dass er jetzt
ein vergessen ebenso eine
sehenswürdigkeit weil auf jeden fall
noch und da sind wir dann wiederum
hingegangen
dort hat er dann noch offen sind wir
darauf eingegangen dass bald auch ganz
cool da aber ich habe ich den namen
vergessen also einer ausstellung und
dort waren wir dann halt drin sind dann
abends wieder zu diesem reichen viertel
sag ich mal gegangen nach paris und
haben dort dann wieder was beim gleichen
restaurant gegessen und dann sind wir
halt dann abends nach hause gegangen
haben dann halt gepennt und am nächsten
tag sehen wir morgens immer zum
eiffelturm gegangen weil davor weil
meine schlechtes wetter als wird zum
turm wollten weil wir wollten auf diese
fläche davor um dort ein paar fotos
gemacht wo man sich halt so auf eine
grünfläche stellt und dann in die hand
hoch hebt das von hörzu eiffelturm kann
den hals umarmen und so weiter so wisst
was ich meine
und da haben wir halt ein paar fotos
gemacht beziehungsweise mutter und eine
schwester wollte fotos machen ich war
dann der [ __ ] denn die ganze kamera
draufhalten musste aber es auch egal
jedenfalls war es halt insgesamt ganz
schön alt nach hause gefahren hatten
dann allerdings noch regen und unwetter
und stau und alles und dann war mein
vater total gestresst und dann haben wir
richtig gas gegeben und dann waren wir
aber jetzt acht wenn ihr dieses video
seht also warte wie wandern am 11 also
am donnerstag den 11 um ca 22 uhr 25
zuhause relativ genau weil genau da habe
ich wieder eine whatsapp bekommen beim
ein internet endlich wieder funktioniert
hat ich weiß nicht warum endlich hier
warum nur hier aber egal wir waren wir
sind aus paris zurück gekommen und man
kann das wissen der deutschen ebay
deutsches netz schalten flugmodus auf
einmal lachend ein netz
ziemlich blöd naja also insgesamt muss
ich echt sagen paris war sehr sehr
schönes wunderschöne stadt ist echt
krass ich hatte gar keine erwartungen an
die stadt ich habe meinen eltern sofort
am anfang gesagt ja wenn ihr nach paris
wollte von mir aus gerne ich kommen wird
aber ich weiß nicht wirklich was ich da
soll ich lass mich einfach mal
überraschen so nach dem motto no risk no
fun sage ich mal ich komme einfach mal
mit ich weiß gar nicht was mich da
erwartet was es dort zu sehen gibt aber
ich komme einfach mal mit und ich muss
sagen ich war positiv überrascht es gibt
das ist es gibt einfach extrem schöne
ecken nur das bild das die leute dort
extrem und freundlich sind
wenn du wirklich kein französisch ganz
bitter direkt am arsch weil die tu nicht
so als ob sich verstehen weil es einfach
keinen bock auf englisch haben das ist
einfach so dass keine ahnung warum die
das machen die wollen eigentlich nur ihr
geld machen und warum sie dann das so
machen aber ist egal
die borders gerade hier alles 33
hofwiese hab ich das hier oben alle
schon weg genommen
versteh nicht mehr hier ist das egal
jedenfalls muss ich echt sagen wenn ihr
mal städtereise macht also wir machen
jedes jahr im herbst ihn wie seine
städtereise waren bisher in london
venedig paris und nächstes jahr wird es
glaube ich new york sein wenn meine
schwester und ich uns da korrekt
durchsetzen können eventuell werde ich
dort dann auch mal ein paar videos
aufnehmen und hochladen auf den zweit
kanal konz block und dann werdet ihr
davon auch ein bisschen was sehen so wie
ich das sehe so also das war erstmal zum
thema paris und jetzt haben sich
bestimmt schon einige gedacht bei euch
halt einfach mal ab weil der bauherr
nicht nur die monster falle aber ich
will halt nicht schieben und deswegen
brauche ich das jetzt auch als einfach
nur und da habe ich halt das thema ganz
gut genutzt
also das war ganz passend dass ich das
hier direkt zu machen konnte perfekte
themen nutzen hier noch sagen was noch
so in paris das so ja ich habe meinen
schnupfen dort dagelassen einfach also
ich bin wieder fit gesund munter und
hier regnet es gerade draußen und ich
denke wir werden heute einfach mal eine
etwas längere folge machen
die wird dann für mich zwar lange zum
hochladen dauern aber daumen hoch wenn
es euch gefällt nein spaß
und ich muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen ich
habe mir in der zeit wo ich in paris war
habe ich ja gesagt aber videos angeguckt
nein nix auf irgendwelchen webseiten
vernehme ich jetzt gar nichts sagen will
sondern auf youtube und zwar von peas
mit i und zwar habe ich mir bei denen da
das together angeguckt und zwar habe ich
erst mal ich habe ab und zu bei dem
gucke ich immer rein
welcher typ man sich auf total nett
finden und so weit so finde ich echt
extrem krass was die fanarbeiter auf
youtube machen und hab ich mir damals
ein paar folgen angeguckt und zwar habe
ich mal so zwischendurch noch folge 60
mal folge 90 also immer so auf dem kanal
war ich so alle zwei wochen war
mal schauen wir diese neue let's play
star hatten fifa 13 ultimate team gucke
ich mir von denen an
und naja jedenfalls habe ich mit ein
paar minecraft reingezogen und hab dann
folge 110 110 sondern folge 90 bis 100
ungefähr geguckt als ich in paris war
kann ich mir gedacht
die erzählen da so viele storys und so
die allen vorherigen folgen schon mal
passiert sind da fängst einmal von vorne
an
da ich mir insgesamt in den fünf tagen
den ich in paris verfolgen 0 bis 60 also
folge 160 angesehen und muss sagen das
ist das geilste together was ich
wirklich je gesehen habe weil die
einfach so die einzigen leute sind die
nicht einfach nur rum lauf und ärzte
aufbauen und kommentare beantworten
sowie den optisch sondern ganz einfach
auch trollen und da hab ich den mal
gesagt weil wir nicht gedacht zur
together show trollen und so weiter also
zwischendurch ein bisschen ärgern bis
und fun damit immer richtig was zu
lachen haben machen die eigentlich nur
wenn wir auch screening satz spielen wie
battlefield oder fifa oder so da träumt
man schon immer gegenseitig nur halt in
der aufnahme wollte mir das immer
vermeiden weil wenn wir gäste haben ist
es natürlich blöd wenn wir dann da ihm
wie mit tnt ankommen oder irgendwas da
anzünden oder so weil dann die sachen
von denen natürlich weg aber uns
gegenseitig wollten wir uns schon ein
wenig träumen
da wollte ich euch einfach mal fragen ob
ihr dafür sollte das dehner und ich uns
ein wenig trollen in der today show also
wir hatten ja als erstmal minecraft
pocket zu gast beziehungsweise der es
immer noch zu gast der ist bis folge
moment natürlich ganz kurz besuchen wir
aufgenommen wie ein langer aufgenommen
der ist bis einschließlich folge 24 pro
folge 24 zu gast bei wiederholt falsch
gemacht der es bis einschließlich folge
24 zu gast bei uns also das ist ganz
cool eigentlich dann auch gewesen und
damit wieder über verschiedene themen
gequatsche abfolge 24 also in folge 25
geht's dann los
da hatten wir dann als neues konzept
also nichts neues konzept es wird
allgemein weiter gehen immer so mit
gästen hatten wir gedacht dass wir
allgemein immer uns gegenseitig ein paar
fallen machen irgendwann fängt einer an
zu trollen
ich habe ihn ja allgemein schon ziemlich
ziemlich oft getötet ohne dass es
irgendwie gerecht hat was ich ganz geil
finde aber werden halt beschlossen dass
wir nicht soviel trollen weil wir hatten
es in der in unserem alten together
hatten wir jetzt zwar gemacht das wird
dort eine menge geträumt haben also auch
gegenseitig und angezündet und getötet
und ich habe ihn ja voll aufgeht nervt
einfach indem ich immer vor seiner
haustür stand und so und wir wollten das
eigentlich lassen bei der today show
jetzt aber da hab ich mir gedacht ist
eigentlich noch ganz witzig wenn man das
mal gemacht und jetzt eher allgemein
alles nur ein spiel
deswegen frage ich da einfach mal was
ihr davon haltet also wollte das werk
rollen oder wollte es ja nicht und
können wir könnt ihr uns einfach in die
kommentare schreiben also jetzt mir in
dieser folge und ja der wird
wahrscheinlich auch bald das sechs
kilometer kreft verwenden also der wird
noch fragen bei facebook ob er das auch
verwenden soll oder so als ich werde
ihnen irgendwie übersehen dass er es
auch nicht weil bei euch kam es extrem
gut an das texture pack und ja ich würde
sagen den ersten haben wir hier schon
fast fertig ok oder auch nur nicht
moment ja doch noch diese wand und zwar
kann ich euch einmal ganz kurz sagen wie
ich mir das in ungefähr vorgestellt habe
dadurch dass er nur kurz ab wenn wir
noch eben hier wunderschön die nase
putzen ohne dass ich irgendwie stoppen
muss doch muss ich schon so das hat
jetzt nicht gehört aber mein headset hat
sich verwickelte okay gut passt ich habe
mir gedacht dass die ganzen leute wo
bist du dann frage ich mich aber gerade
recht wussten export hier vielleicht
oder da oben er da oben hundertprozentig
oben
ich kann das gar nichts über nicht muss
es nachher noch abbauen
ich habe mir gedacht dass die hier
nachhaltig auf der fläche dar und dass
die dann hier sind so wasser flüsse und
dann werden die da halt reingedrängt in
diese wasser flüsse und müssen in diesem
wasser flüssen dann quasi werden sie
dann runter gespielt und dann sind gibt
es hier solche löcher also warum ich das
jetzt gerade so abgebaut habe weiß ich
selber nicht
aber ich zeit mal ganz kurz hier wieder
zu damit ihr ungefähr seht was ich meine
und zwar werden die dann halt mal was
richtig schwer gemacht
ich versteh gar nicht was wir bräuchten
jetzt ab hier gibt's diese neue presse
auch falsch na ja es wird noch richtig
aussehen ich spüre bei irgendwas hier
gibt's diese wasser flüsse das heißt das
wasser fließt von hier ist genau hier
ist genau hier
und dann gibt es hier diese teile diese
nach unten gehen dort fallen die dann
nach unten in einem planschbecken
dort kriegen sie schon fall schaden und
dann werden sie noch mal einen lava
becken gedrängt wo sieht allerdings nur
durch fallen bzw durch geschleudert
werden sag ich mal
und dort werden sie dann wiederum
gegrillt sag ich mal das heißt zombie
vielleicht wird dann direkt gebraten
oder ich weiß gar nicht ob das in dieser
version schon geht aber jedenfalls
werden die dort dann gechillt und ich
kann hier unten ganz einfach die ganzen
items von den schnecken und ich muss sie
dann halt kein bisschen schlagen ihr
denkt jetzt bestimmt was ich schlage
nach krise gar keine xp ich weiß aber
das bringt mir ja hier auch nix weil ich
spiele eine beta 1.5 da gibst du was wie
xp noch nicht kommt man dass man gar
nicht buchstabieren und naja also warten
wir hier eine spinne 7 8 9 10 und dann
habe ich mir gedacht das halt einerseits
monster bei den monsters bonner dort
spawn und andererseits auf welche auf
den namen also ich ihn nehmen also die
wasserbecken hier sind ja die arme sag
ich mal mit arme meine ich jetzt diese
flächen die ich immer so zwischen den
ganzen
wasserarme aushöhle also diese flächen
sind quasi die anderen spawn flächen für
andere monster für zombies und so weiter
weil ich will ja nicht dass nur nach her
dass ich nur knochen habe und nur feile
wohlfeile wäre natürlich auch ganz cool
aber halt es auch da so ein paar andere
sachen ist ein bisschen variabilität
kann man das sagen dass wir variabel
sind bei solchen dingen batterien müssen
übrigens elf glaube ich oder also ich
denke wir müssen 11 11 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 sehr schön da ist tag des tages
tag
es ist schon wieder noch thor gott ich
quatsch wieder so viel
naja ist ja auch egal jedenfalls müssen
wir uns dafür gleich auch noch wasser
holen
also ist er noch mehr nein nein hier ist
wieder so dass reinfall becken das
planschbecken also die dann runter
fallen
was waren das für magna
schon wieder da ich hoffe ich habe mich
grad gemietet wenn nicht dann hab ich
vergessen habt ihr toll gehört wie ich
wusste wenn es spontan kommt also hört
sich ziemlich affig an
also hier sind diese flächen wo die
monster spawnen also zombies etc und die
waadt stellt hier dann so hin blablabla
gehen hier die wasser flüsse und
verändern darunter also so stelle ich
mir das vor
da hat mir gedacht dass eventuell nicht
zwei hoch lassen weil dann könnte der
zombies porn aber keine änderungen gibt
es nicht von der macht einfach mal drei
hochvolt dann allgemein mehr sportler
das plakat aus kombi wenn inventars von
83 sand weg 8 hast du auch so blöd dass
ich jetzt mal dieser bug dass man
teilweise aus dem fenster wirklich raus
geht wenn man was aus dem inventar
schmerzen wirkung so wie ich aus dem
fenster raus und so weiter
deshalb behält also ich würde sagen sie
sind schon relativ weit gekommen also
dafür dass sich die ganze zeit wirklich
nur bei paris gequatscht ob ich jetzt
ein bisschen abgebaut hat ist das schon
ziemlich weit vor allem muss aufpassen
spitzhacke gleich kaputt zwar genau
jetzt
jetzt weiß ich nicht solche ebene neue
machen ich kann mir eigentlich eben
sogar keck an ich nicht weil ich kein
eisen wirklich dabei hat das heißt ich
gehe jetzt eben zurück hoffe dass ich da
bin ich sterbe aber es ist mein mann
sieht schon dass es ein monster falle
wird aus tag sehr genau dafür
irgendeinen erhält egal
im januar greift mich nicht und ich sage
noch extra greift nicht an da sonst
hätte
pfeile
das bringt es eigentlich gar nicht dass
ich mit meinen drei pfeile abschießen
und ich dann einen fall bekomme das
bringt kein bisschen was naja die bäume
sehen auf denen die bäume sehen auf
jeden fall schon mal ganz schön aus
muss ich sagen also sehen noch nicht so
wie palm aus aber auf jeden fall schon
mal ganz schön und die werde ich auch
erst mal stehen lassen damit wir uns ja
so einen kleinen wald ansiedeln können
haben jetzt eigentlich noch mehr reisen
ich habe etwas gefahr bestimmt was ich
packe meinen ganzen koalitionsreihen
dann bauen uns einfach irgendwann soll
riesig fetten turm einfach total sicher
vor allem möglichen troll attacken ist
was eigentlich gar nicht passieren kann
weil wir hier keine anderen leute auf
dem linken sei es egal wenn irgendwann
mal wo das wetter schwung der audiospur
wenn irgendwann mal jemand rollen sollte
dann sind wir aber gewappnet
meine damen und er vielleicht ein wenig
applaus so ich wollte man einmal wasser
holen und wir haben leute in die
kommentare geschrieben wie ich eine farm
mache danke danke danke
und zwar geht das so moment habe ich
überhaupt noch nicht ob nicht
im moment ich zeige euch wie es geht
ich habe mich gefragt wie man an samen
rankommt und dann dachte ich okay neuen
version kriegt man samen von gras hier
geht es so irgendwer meinte man muss
links oder rechts mit der hochofen wtf
man muss links oder rechts klick mit der
haut ich hab kein verein wird man muss
entweder linksklick oder rechts mit der
hof groß machen warum geht jetzt nicht
wtf also bitte wenn ihr wisst wie ich an
samen komme also mir wurde gesagt mit
der hohen linksklick auf links bitte
wenn ihr es wisst einfach mal die
kommentare schreiben wenn ich euch sehr
verbunden
danke also an alle die jetzt überhaupt
noch zugucken bezahlt wenn die
kommentare schreiben
das wäre ich total nett von euch so wir
machen uns jetzt erstmal spitzhacken und
ich möchte dass auch eigentlich fertig
kriegen da sie noch in dieser session
heute weil ganz einfach ich will nicht
etwas unangetastet hier oder unfertiges
hier stehen lassen wir uns übrigens auch
das wasser dafür dass wir das endlich
sonne unendliche quelle und diese ganzen
abflüsse machen können dann ist das euch
wahrscheinlich schon viel mehr klar wie
ich mir das vorstelle ich mache jetzt
mal hier sein sohn beckenbauer das wird
halten extrem krasse folge damit habe
ich schon die von den letzten beiden
malen eingeholt also von dem letzten mal
vor allem so schön das funktioniert
schauen wir dann haben wir das reinfall
becken für die penner scheiß zombies und
so
und ich glaube irgendwo für brauchen wir
später auch den kommissionen also ich
las denen erst mal da drinnen
ich las den ich behalte ihn erstmal und
schmeißt den jetzt nicht weg nicht so
hier ist noch eine fackel so dass der
zweite abfluss der dritte da ist es
nicht ein bisschen zu wenig was
rausgekommen habe ich weiß gar nicht ich
probier's mal ganz kurz kommt erstmal
mit lee passt auch perfekt sehr schön da
müssen wir noch ein bisschen abbauen und
dann können wir die eigentlich schon mal
testen ehe ich lass uns erstmal mit dem
testen bis die komplett fertig ist dann
machen wir halt eine extreme gefolge die
dann irgendwie 50 minuten lang geht oder
so oder ich mache das andere dann
einfach in der nächsten dann hatte ich
mal war dann habe ich auch richtig lang
aufgenommen
richtiger hengst nein spaß ich bin doch
kein hengst ich hengst wie sie bräuchten
wieder rein ich bin zurück ich und blöd
also desto länger man aufnimmt desto
blöder wird man echt bord apropos blöd
da wo sie eine story erzählen kommst du
nach hause war sie in mein zimmer machst
du pc an guckst du youtube was so los
war mir so statistiken an cook zum uk
guckst du neueste folge kommentare eine
person einen daumen hoch irgendwie 50
uhr unter beiden kommentar und als spam
gemeldet der domhof wahrscheinlich auch
von sich selber so konkret da du penner
hat ich habe keinen chatfunktion
deswegen kann ich das nicht schreiben
contra fiat panda aidoo voll scheiße du
von abos und so du voll schlechte pvp
und so du voll schlecht daumen dislike
blockiere mich doch du [ __ ]
irgendwie sowas und ich so alter die ist
klar dass es mich geschrieben
ob captain ivo wir sinken weil dann
einfach so witzig fanden ich wollte ihn
einfach provozieren das ändern er
schreibt dann kommt er an und die also
du [ __ ] blog dem ich voll doch du
bist voll hintritt und so weiter und
nicht so ok ich hab' so geschrieben
wieso sollte ich dich blockieren ich
finde das voll witzig wie du hier die
kommentare steps bringt uns alle zu
machen und vor allem kann jeder auf der
welt eine dummheit erst in den
kommentaren entziffern und dann hat er
erstmal nichts mehr geschrieben aber ein
anderer hat
blieben also eigentlich stellt man
solche dramatik schwierigkeiten nur bei
türken fest oder ausländern die gerade
nach deutschland gekommen sind ich weiß
auch dass beide der fall ist würde ich
nicht beleidigen und so also wirklich
nett geschrieben oder so nichts gegen
ausländer also feindlich oder nicht
ausländerfeindlich oder so ganz im
gegenteil ich finde es gut wenn viele
leute nach deutschland kommen aber es
ist halt so dass wirklich ausländer dann
oft irgendwelche sprach jetzt nicht so
viel beherrschen findet zwar nicht
schlimm aber halt auch ein anderer typ
geschrieben ich zitiere das gerade durch
wenn meine eigene meinung gar nicht mit
einbringen ich zitiere ihnen so halt ja
kann es sein dass du ihm die ausländer
bist und deswegen geschmack nicht so gut
beherrscht oder mit seiner auf morgen
und er so häufig die stimme ab fick dich
ich gebe dir du [ __ ] und alter da
denke ich echt so manche leute lernen
einfach nicht dazu ich meine hier in der
höhle oder auch nicht
oder doch die habe ich das zeitlich
gesehen
krass damit direkt lama vorrat für die
monster fälle
doch hier war ich doch schon her oder
ist ein zombie irgendwo direkt lover vor
ort für die falle
das ist ja geil und jetzt noch kohle und
dann diese person hat dann wirklich
nichts mehr geschrieben in den letzten
neun stunden obwohl sie halt online
warnt bei anderen videos kommentiert hat
ich glaube dann wenn die schnauze voll
habe ich mir gedacht okay kommen jetzt
kannst du dir blockieren weil solche
leute will ich einfach nicht in der
community haben und die blockiere ich
dann einfach direkt weil nicht weil er
mich beleidigt hat sondern weil er
einfach nicht also ohne grund sag ich
mal beleidigt hat weil er gesagt hatte
du bist voll die [ __ ] und so also
erst mal ich bin nicht schwul
also das erstmal so grob voran jetzt
hier
ich habe nichts gegen schwule und ich
wünsch wachtel ist auch keine
beleidigung
das ist genauso als wenn du zu jemand
sagt also eher eine [ __ ] ist halt
eine person die steht auf männer
und das ist genauso als würde man sagen
ey du hetero oder so weil stets darauf
blabla und also ich finde das ist
eigentlich keine beleidigung das ist
mehr sonne sonne
ich sag mal beschreibungen nachricht
bekommen pro match
ok ich hab keinen bock auf fußball mein
gott was wollen die denn die wollen eine
fußball spielen das ist total scheiß
wetter draußen naja egal jedenfalls
finde ich halt total schrecklich wenn
solche leute einerseits das machen wenn
sie sich dafür nicht entschuldigen hat
es nochmal anderen grad und wenn sie
sich nicht entschuldigen und trotzdem
weitermachen das finde ich schlimm ich
meine ich habe mir sogar noch gesagt
durch meine kommentare so die ist klar
dass das jeder lesen kann und alle gegen
dich sind mehr willst du damit nicht
mehr aufhören so nach dem motto mehr
macht als geld weiter so ist nicht mein
problem ist sein problem aber wenn er
weitermachen will von mir aus naja ich
hab jetzt auf den teil blockiert ich
werde euch nicht sagen welche personen
das ist ganz einfach weil ich nicht will
dass in diese person hated das war
nämlich auch der fall dass jemand bei
mir und ein video geschrieben hat oder
das hat keiner und ein video geschrieben
das habe ich in einem anderen video
gesehen da hat ein typ darunter
geschrieben erster und dann hat er sich
selber geantwortet
ey du bist voll behindert worden
schreibt zuerst da und der hat sich
wirklich selber geantwortet nur um viele
likes zu bekommen und
dann hab ich dann halt bei facebook
gepostet ohne den namen zu zensieren
weil ich es irgendwie vergessen habe und
habe dann wirklich so dumm da
geschrieben beantwortet sich selber wtf
und dann dort waren fehler dann wurde
der halt ein bisschen gerettet aber dann
habe ich halt gesagt hört bitte auf die
zu helfen und dann ging das eigentlich
auch wieder klar nur ich finde also ich
denn in zukunft keine namen mehr auch
bei facebook bilden oder so macht ihr zu
mit seinem schwarzen streifen und ganz
einfach damit so ein bisschen diskretion
damit die auch ihre privatsphäre weile
haben und nicht für unnötigen staat
gerettet werden so dass zu dem thema und
ich würde sagen ich noch jetzt mal ein
aufnahmestopp und zwar ziemlich wieder
wtf 50 minuten fast alter freund waren
es noch 30
naja gut also ich muss echt sagen ein
bisschen weit gekommen mit dieser
monster falle creative mord hat das
ganze wahrscheinlich zwei minuten zwei
minuten gedauert oder so aber ich finde
dafür dass wir hier alles im survival
mode hin klatschen und alles wirklich
mit der hand ab bauen ist das schon
extrem geil vor allem mit ganzen eisen
spitzhacke und wer noch keinen einzigen
diamanten von dass es in der höhle gehen
wirklich so nach diamanten suchen
und naja also ihr wird jetzt auf jeden
fall meine denkweise über spezielle
themen wie es in paris war wie ich jetzt
fand und ich kann euch echt allen nur
empfehlen dorthin zu fahren wenn ihr
wirklich eine städtereise machen wollt
paris ist leicht wunderschön
dann würde ich sagen diese kleine
flächen mit danach mache ich dann eben
einen stock ducati fläche ist größer als
ich dachte ich kann ja schon mal sagen
wenn euch das video gefallen hat dann
würde ich mich definitiv über einen
daumen hoch freuen es ist nicht weil ich
bin sondern einfach dass ich so hat euch
gefallen oder hat euch nicht gefallen
wenn du natürlich viele like sind sieht
man das hat ihnen gefallen vielleicht
sollte ich öfters mal so ein bisschen
mehr aus um im real life erzählen oder
als hat ihm nicht gefallen er aber
andere team ansprechen und so also das
sieht man daran schon immer ganz gut
also deswegen bitte ein daumen hoch
geben wenn es euch gefallen hat und dann
würde ich einfach mal sagen den ersten
abend haben wir schon fertig den zweiten
lauf fast dann müssen wir in der
nächsten auf den drittplatzierten machen
und dann würde ich sagen sie uns in der
nächsten folge lost nächstes wochenende
wieder samstagabend
abend bei deiner mittag und ja bis zum
nächsten mal